have you heard of cocaine bear I know I
think is that gay porn no
hottest movie trended on Twitter
yesterday based on a real story in
November 1985 a hunter discovered a dead
175 pound black bear in Chattahoochee
National Forest nearby was a duffel bag
that had originally contained roughly 75
pounds of cocaine the unfortunate animal
had apparently gotten into the blow and
overdosed later dubbed Pablo Esco bear
or simply cocaine bear and now they're
making a movie about it oh oh I hope
Pixar's all over this
by the way that's 85 before fentanyl you
know that bear would have been dead in
two seconds but at least he probably had
a good run around the forest with that
coke yeah I know but yeah that's the
thing dude you know you've got to scrape
the barrel if you're not going to do
more redones of top gun
that has taken cocaine that's what's
happening next that's gold I love it and
nobody gets hurt you can't cancel
anybody it's fun he's already a black
bear we're in big inclusive
sorry what'd you say the bed's not very
happy no no but you get a bear you know
he won't really do Coke in the movie
yeah it'll be fake Coke and it'll also
be a fake bet apparently he's on display
the guy it's been what's it called when
you do it Taxidermy yeah Taxidermy
cocaine whoa serious [ __ ] still got the
white stuff on his muzzle and everything
damn that's awesome good for the bear
yeah I think you had a good time um
another thing happy like he went out
like Rick James
I remembered that tweet from that lady a
few it was about 10 years ago do you
remember she there was some lady that
was flying to Africa oh yeah the AIDS
lady
dude that story came back up again what
I just I it resurfaced someone was
reflecting it because it's nearly 10
years since it happened and that was
still that was like cancellation before
cancellation right so for the people
that don't know this lady was flying to
Africa South Africa I think and tweeted
um going to Africa hope I don't get AIDS
just kidding I'm white and she got on
the plane with a life and a career and
got off the plane and it was
all gone yeah poor girl that's not a bad
that's not that bad there's a lot of
AIDS in Africa
uh not really amongst the whites I mean
if you go with the statistics I'm with
her
hey you know it's a funny joke but uh
that should be a mini series like HBO
like black mirror and all that how about
all the true cancels throughout the last
you know get Kramer in there get uh the
AIDS lady get Roseanne remember the
ambient tweet wow that would be
interesting that would be good each one
is a different character each one is a
different story cancellation Through the
Ages exactly see what they had and see
what they lost Roseanne had the biggest
show on Netflix that went away you know
that that's fun stuff it seems like I
mean is there anyone Trump gone now back
there's no one really that's too big to
to topple I don't think is there anyone
that's outside of the cancellation verse
Chappelle seems pretty uh Invincible yes
he's quarantined somehow yeah I don't
know how I think he just doesn't care
and he's a cool black guy and he sells
out everywhere if you have the capital
you can kind of Beat It I lied to JK
Rowling ah there's another one Capital
she's a zillionaire yes I think ability
to win people money is just a protective
mechanism right cute why would you kill
the Golden Goose right right yeah which
is kind of fun because it shows how much
[ __ ] a lot of this is because
they're like yes that's horrible oh wait
you know let's not say it about her
let's not say it about him oh he doesn't
how much does he not put your 10 mil no
yeah we can get rid of him exactly yeah
Alec Baldwin's still working wow [ __ ]
dude that's insane I talked about a
life-changing like that
bro brutal poor guy
well he's back on filming the same movie
is he yeah oh man imagine that one year
finally we get back to set Jesus Christ
yeah geez I hope they got a new um prop
guy
you know that gun guy whoever that was
or that lady
[ __ ] dude I mean that's that's one of
the wildest one of the wildest and
that's just gone you know that's just
like in the past and that feels like it
was the same as the AIDS lady ten years
ago now right it's not what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
thank you